Hikaru an impressive performance all
around you started off with this very
intriguing opening Choice how did you
come up with the Kalashnikov
yeah I mean there are a couple things
first of all uh you know I'm just here
to have fun so why not play something to
surprise my opponents uh you know I did
it against Sam against Lanier felt the
same way
um yeah I mean I've played every slain
Under the Sun again so we've obviously
played many times but I just want to do
something different and he spent a lot
of time and I think in the one control
format it's very very difficult if you
got way down on the clock and somewhere
in the middle game I felt good but I
lost the threat a little bit
um I mean the first thing is like yeah
obviously if you go back here I'm in and
this route to B8 was very intriguing as
well yeah well I mean this is the Parham
line not suitable plays this all the
time
um but yeah I mean the thing is uh like
Knight D5 is the best move
um like 95 takes takes in 97 but I mean
the big thing here is that of course uh
the computer doesn't even okay the weak
engines don't even say what the best
move is yeah of course yeah I mean I
don't play chess so I can say this but
yeah G4 is obviously the best movement
it's very very sharp and nobody knows
what's going on but if you don't know
that's the move it's almost impossible
to play yeah ideas were actually guessed
it and he didn't have the engines yeah I
mean it's easy to uh it
ain't because I mean if Yasser was
playing he plays G4 and lose everyone's
going to pretty much tell him like you
know you say don't do this don't do that
you push a pawn you lose like a clown
and you're you're just a total idiot so
I mean it's much different because when
you're not playing yeah like if you
suggest movement is bad I mean there's
nothing can go wrong really but when
you're in the moment playing obviously
it's very difficult and um I had a
feeling that linear wasn't going to play
it I thought he would play G3 and I mean
I thought it should have been completely
fine in this opening um but somewhere I
lost the thread yeah I like I thought
yeah that's okay don't worry I've done
that um but yeah if you go back to round
B4 around move 20 yeah like keep going
keep going yeah we castle Yeah somewhere
around here I thought I should be fine
but I lost the thread when I went Knight
C5 I don't know if B4 was better or
before it was one of the top moves I
think and F5 as well because basically
what I decided was some yeah I just
miscalculated the Slime Knight C5 Queen
E2 Queen C7 and I just
just completely underestimated B4 and F
B4 and Rook A5 sorry
um and then like yeah already here I
mean probably for a computer it's still
okay but I I didn't feel very good about
it because I thought I had it all under
control and then I didn't and I didn't
have to give up the bishop yeah I taken
them play 905 and I I still wasn't so
sure though
um
I played Rook A7 which I thought was re
I thought he could actually take the
pawn too I was yes I was a little
surprised that he didn't do it because
it looks kind of ugly after Knight takes
E3 uptakes E3
but I'm not able to win back the pawn
right away and yeah I can play ignite B6
or something but if I'm not getting F5
and E4 in like say just play just play
Knight B6 or okay fine whatever just
play Knight B6 I don't know some stupid
move King H1 F5 King G1 E4 like if I get
this where the bishop on G2 is very bad
this should be very good for me but the
problem is I thought that in this line
uh instead of like King H1 of course
after Knight B6 that white can go like
E4 here at some point
maybe maybe it doesn't maybe this
position doesn't work but I thought like
if I'm not getting F5 E4 I thought that
white white should just be up the pawn I
mean okay obviously here I guess it
doesn't work but yeah but yeah like I
thought here that I was in trouble then
he played Rook A7
and I thought I was once again
completely okay yeah
were you playing for an advantage right
now well see here I thought it was
completely fine and then about three
moves later I I thought I was suddenly
in a lot of trouble okay this was the
critical moment though you played Knight
F6 Bishop G5 King to G7 and G2 H3 and
you spent quite a lot of time here
almost 20 minutes this is ah I can
actually go King G5 wow I mean I spent a
lot of time because yeah it's on 97 and
97 is what I want to do but takes takes
an F4 uh and originally I thought I had
Queen A7 King H1 and queen D4 but this
actually loses to uh Queen F1 I believe
yes and and then you take the check on
E5 and the king is completely exposed so
this was the original idea then yeah I
kind of thought I could maybe take on F4
but it just I don't know it looks so
ridiculous and now you go to Jesus Queen
F6 Queen E3 or something
Queen F6 Queen E3 and yeah you're
actually winning this one
yeah I mean from a distance I saw that I
could play this but it just it looks it
looks so bad so this was your main
line that you were calculating yeah it
was calculated this for a long time and
then finally when I when I just saw my
Kings to open and I started looking
other lines I thought I came up with
this Knight D4 idea I mean initially
actually I also thought after see after
C3 I could play Rook A3 here but this
actually loses I think is why you can
take and go Queen E4
and if I take on C3 there's Rook D4 Rook
C1 King G2 takes Queen F4 now you have
some Knight beat I
P3 here which is okay yeah I mean this
loses of course because Rook C1 Queen F4
yeah actually Queen D4 first is better
but you can even take a check and then
yeah yeah but
so Knight B3 okay I mean yeah again this
is this Indian chess yeah yeah so then
what I thought was not done so then
after C3 I came up with this other idea
I thought well now I can go Knight C2
and put the Knight on A3 and then put
the Knight on C4 this is actually what I
thought I mean it looks kind of weird
but if I get the Knight to C4 suddenly
both of those Knights are very well
placed yeah
um so this I thought was an idea and I
didn't see what I didn't see a way for
white to win here so I figure if it's
not not winning and Lenny being low on
time I can just kind of go and do
whatever and probably the best for him
would have been to go Rook dito Rook D1
and yeah but it's very hard to because
like you don't know like is should white
be better should white should black be
better like if the game goes on who's
better it's not really clear with the
Bishops versus the knights so I thought
yeah Queen after I think was a mistakes
after an IGA I mean White's probably
still okay but now I think it becomes
very hard to play because in the long
term the night on G8 should be better
than the vishwan G5 yeah and of course I
can always put the other Knight on A3 so
and very cool idea towards the end was
uh this H5 move yeah it doesn't seem
like you have anything more to do but
finally yeah I mean he kept defending
ridiculously while I was waiting for him
to make a blunder and then he kept kept
playing good moves
um and yeah H5 I don't know if it's
actually winning but I mean ideas oh it
is okay well I mean it's also hard for
me because I don't have the moves like
originally I thought he had blundered
Rook A3 I thought Rook A3 like Queen C4
and some 95 or something is good but of
course on Rook A3 there's Bishop C1
instead of Queen C4 and now I think if
anything white might be better that's
right that's right yeah yeah so you
closed the show quite nicely with this
yeah Checkmate that you would probably
see every Tuesday in here something like
that yeah I mean it would have been nice
if I like he well I guess Queen g1's
made in one but if I could get 95 93
even better but all right it's too too
much you will be playing the winner of
Fabi versus Wesley how do you see that
match play out which is actually
starting in just yeah I mean I think
that's a coin flip it just depends who
who probably who gets a better position
out of the opening
um or who's up on time when they get
into the scramble I don't really see any
big difference between either of them I
mean Fabiano I don't remember was this
last year's championship or the previous
one who Fabiano won the last one right
so it would have been two years ago
there's that Wesley won in the
tiebreaker but in like I'm thinking of
that tie breaker and I think Fabiano got
a much better position maybe even
winning then of course got too low on
time messed it all up Wesley ended up
winning so I I think there's very little
difference between them and it doesn't
really matter who I play hikar thank you
very much congratulations once again
we'll see you tomorrow our
congratulations as well fantastic game
by Hikaru as we get ready for the
playoffs